what do you actually think happened with
this Paul Pelosi thing take off your you
know Republican you're hanging out with
those guys crew and just give be a fact
Checker what do you actually think
happened here because the stories are so
crazy and the allegations are so the
part is that's concerning is that NBC
changed the story twice took a video
down they put it up it went down it's
you know we can't talk about that we're
learning stuff no we can't and then hey
this is really you know they're going
after her and then you know Nancy so a
lot of uh a lot of weird things going on
there here's my theory that it would
account for all the facts as we know
them now not even as we know them at the
beginning sure so you got this wacky
dude yeah David all agree he's a wacky
okay he's a wacky dude and and we can
all agree also that sometimes when
you're mentally paranoid you will pick
up a grab bag of conspiracies and wild
ideas so this guy is a Berkeley nudist
he's lgbtq but he still thinks the
election was stolen so he he's not a
political you can't place him on the
Spectrum he's a paranoid right yes
somehow he figures out and I don't know
how he did this but he figures out how
to get into the Pelosi house right he
gets in I think what happens is because
he's a nut he starts engaging Paul
Pelosi right but he doesn't threaten him
he doesn't threaten him because that
explains the NBC report Paul Pelosi
comes through the door first of all Paul
Pelosi does not tell the cops he's being
attacked he doesn't say that he says
come do a wellness check on me right he
knows the guy's name he goes the guy's
name is David and he's a friend now the
left has been saying the reason he said
he's a friend is because you know he had
to he had to sort of get on the good
side of this guy but that doesn't square
with the fact that that the guy let him
do a bathroom break where supposedly he
was charging his phone he wasn't with
the guy he could have told the cops
anything but why'd he let him in the
house not only why do you live in no the
guy broken the dead break he did break
in but but here's my point you're in the
bathroom a normal person would lock the
bathroom door until the cop gets there
right he didn't do that he goes back out
number two when the cops show up
apparently Paul Pelosi lets them in and
turns around and returns to the house
that's when the guy attacks him so think
about this no normal person if you're in
real fear the guy threatened you I'm
gonna smash your head with a hammer are
you would run out of the door into the
protection of the cops and let them go
in the house so all of this I think what
happened with NBC is they put this out
and suddenly people realize Paul Pelosi
was not really scared of this guy for
whatever reason and then they realized
that doesn't fit the narrative we got to
take it down so this is what I'm only
all over this because I hate to be like
given a given a story and then expect me
to like just take it because you said it
but go deeper some guy breaks into your
house right and I think Paul Pelosi was
sleeping it's 2 30 in the morning he's
in his underwear cool whatever right are
you not freaking out paranoid trying to
shoot the guy locking yourself like
what's this whole like by the way the
friend thing like how often do you say
like hey how's our friend doing how's
our friend and we're not he's not our
friend it's some guy we you know that
may be showing up like just for a
meeting hey our friend you use this term
a lot our friend hey how's our friend so
I'm kind of dismissing that but like if
some guy breaks in your house you're not
trying to talk to this guy you're not
getting buddy buddy you you're freaking
out what the [ __ ] you're doing to my
house like what is this exchange that
they're actually having I think that and
I only say this because I mean it's kind
of funny yesterday I was at the airport
right and I'm just waiting to pick up my
bags and literally this Hasidic guy
comes up to me and starts like really
engaging me in intense conversation and
not sort of like hey didn't actually
like your work or something like that
but he starts talking to me about in the
Hasidic Community he goes we started
growing vegetables on my on my balcony
and he says have you are you familiar
with the Hasidic newspaper I'm like no
you know I'm not Hasidic you know so
what I'm getting at is is there are a
lot of cooks right and and you can
pretty well in a in almost a moment pick
up if someone is just a nut right and
they want to like and and when someone
is in the political domain you get
approached by lunatics by the way there
are plenty of lunatics on the right and
on the left yeah and they're always
handing you material they want you to
take with you they're always in my case
proposing movies I ought to make they
always want to tell me about their life
story in some cases they think they're
being followed or the FBI is after them
so I think it's something like this this
guy was an animated Kook and he get in
he gets it now Paul Pelosi admittedly
he's not well he is over 80. so he's an
old man but I think what happened is he
he recognized right away this is the
kind of Kook that Nancy and I have been
dealing with for much of this it's our
political lives exactly and so for the
course yeah I better I better see if
some cops will come by make sure I'm
okay yeah I think at that point he was
clearly not under attack because the
attack is at least as far as we know
occurred when the cops were there yeah
but it's so weird because we've all been
approached by random people you're
trying to get out of it you're trying to
be nice but you're also kind of like
kind of got to keep it moving like the
Hasidic guy at the airport that's cool
right I mean you're trying to but this
is in your house at three in the morning
that's so weird to me why you'd be
friendly or whatever kind of atmosphere
I don't know it's not something's not
adding up I mean I still don't know why
the cops didn't shoot the guy because I
don't even mean shoot to kill him but
just at least shoot to disarm him
because if you see a guy with a hammer
hitting Paul Pelosi on the head you
would think you would use Force
immediately and and and you'd use lethal
Force but also you're the you're the
number three in line to the presidency
Nancy Pelosi right right okay she was in
DC I believe at the point so she wasn't
even home but you're the husband hot as
some kooky dude break into your compound
you know you know we talk about Build
That Wall are you kidding me hardly how
did he get in
unanswered unknown weird so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here